I'm Jonathan I the district and town
councillor for Sudbury East
I'm also deputy leader at Weber and I
also cabinet member for housing just a
little bit a bit of background about
myself I work to the local government
for 26 years the first few years was
working in benefits revenues
I was then seconded to the best value
team which became the permanent
corporate performance team and then I
was passionate into planning as it was a
failing service to manage the
administration team my husband and I
motor sovery 20 years ago and we really
loved the area it's fantastic it's got
fantastic people
fantastic voluntary organizations and
the area itself is is fantastic and we
just wanted to put something back into
the community so we thought the best way
of doing that was to become counselors
so I've now been a town councillor for
12 years and I stood for election in
2011 but I lost that by 3 votes but
fortunately I got elected in 2015
shortly after that I was made portfolio
holder for Communities which was a very
rewarding role and then six months later
I was made cabinet member for housing
which is a very extremely challenging
and demanding role so I've been on a
very long journey on a very small space
of time the housing role is extremely
challenged
but I am really fortunate in working
with a team that are very supportive a
very committed and very motivated and
what is best of all is they believe in
what they do
so it's an actually it's a great honor
in working with them I find it so
rewarding dealing with personal people
things rather than the strategic side of
it and one example was I had a lady that
came to me that had got too many health
problems and it also got physical
problems and she wanted something quite
simple as a chair after putting her
house and we together with a
hard-working officer we got back down
and I can remember phoning her hotel in
her and she was crying and I was crying
so that is where it's really so
rewarding so I'm looking forward to the
next 11 months in addition to that
obviously it's a hundred years since
ladies got the vote we're very fortunate
and in Suffolk embalmer that we've got
quite an equality in respect of cabinet
members being being ladies and to have
the housing role is a great honor
especially in this particular year so I
have wanted to work in for the next 11
months just to say I think we've come a
really long way and I think first of all
I think the first thing is that it's
important that women pick up on those
reasons for why we were given the vote
and the effort and sacrifice that those
women went through a hundred years ago
so that we would
so I think it's important that not June
we just hold the role in political
office but also that women go out there
and vote I think that's really important